Aquí tengo una tabla de datos, cuya primera columna, son valores de tiempo
indicándome que
después de 75 segundos
un móvil, un objeto, un cuerpo,
ha recorrido 5 metros
después de 120 segundos
ha recorrido 8 metros,
y después de 270 segundos
se ha recorrido 20 metros.
Quiero mostrar estos datos
en algún tipo de gráfica
y estoy interesado en saber,
¿cuál es la escala que debo de usar
para esa gráfica?
Aquí nos dan 4 opciones para la forma,
más precisamente,
para la escala que debo de utilizar,
para hacer esa gráfica
así por ejemplo, para la opción A
tenemos una escala de 1
para ambos ejes
mientras que, para la opción B
tenemos una escala de 50,
para el eje de segundos
y una escala de 2,
para el eje de metros
y así continúan las demás opciones.
Lo que te pido que hagas ahora
es una pausa en el vídeo
y pienses ¿cuál de estas opciones
cuál de estas escalas
es la más apropiada para graficar
los datos que tenemos aquí?
Bien,
todos los datos son positivos,
así es que puedo restringirme
a la parte positiva del eje "x"
y a la parte positiva del eje "y"
y tomando en cuenta que los segundos
determinan los metros
esta es la variable independiente
y esta es la variable dependiente,
entonces en nuestro eje horizontal...
déjame hacerlo con espacio suficiente
para tener varias gráficas...
entonces, en nuestro eje horizontal,
vamos a tener
los segundos
mientras que
en el eje vertical
vamos a tener
los metros
y aquí voy a poner
algunas marcas generales
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
déjame poner
las más claras aquí
6, 7,
ahora voy a copiar y pegar esto
entonces
pego aquí
y tenemos 2
ahí tenemos una tercera gráfica
y ahí ya tenemos
cuatro gráficas.
Ahora,
voy a incluir las escalas que tenemos aquí,
para que veamos cuál es la mejor opción.
Empecemos entonces con la gráfica A,
digamos que esta es, la gráfica A
y la escala aquí es de 1,
en el eje "s"
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
y también es de 1 en el eje "m"
o eje de metros o eje de distancia
debería de decir
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
tratemos de graficar estos datos
después de 75 segundos,
ha avanzado 5 metros.
Como puedes ver 75 segundos
no aparece en la escala
ni siquiera creo que pudiera aparecer aquí
a la derecha de tu monitor
así es que este dato no aparece aquí,
inclusive estos datos estarían más a la derecha
así es que ninguno de los datos aparecerían,
con la escala que tiene esta gráfica,
sin embargo
creo que aquí
podría intentar algo así,
aquí podría intentar
algo así,
podría indicar
que me estoy brincando unos datos,
esto usualmente se denota
poniendo un hueco ahí
pones una marca como esta
para indicar que brincaste varios datos
y como aún quiero mantener la escala,
de un segundo
aquí podríamos empezar en,
75 segundos
75, 76 acuérdate que estoy indicando que aquí
hay un hueco de 0 a 75 segundos
ya podríamos ahora graficar 75 segundos
y 5 metros que estaría ubicado aquí
pero luego 120 segundos
iría también a la derecha,
en esta gráfica,
8 metros no está incluido en el eje vertical,
270 segundos
no está incluido tampoco en el eje horizontal
como tampoco 20 metros
está incluido en el eje vertical
así es que definitivamente
descartamos esta escala para ambos ejes.
Veamos ahora la gráfica B
la escala en el eje "s" es de 50,
esta es la gráfica B, la escala es,
50, 100, 150,
200,
250,
y aquí tendríamos,
2, 4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14...
veamos entonces,
cómo podríamos graficar nuestros puntos,
el primer punto 75 segundos 5 metros,
y aquí tendríamos 50, 75 más o menos por aquí,
aquí serían 5 metros
el segundo punto sería 120 segundos
y 8 metros
120 segundos y 8 metros,
más o menos por aquí lo tenemos
el tercer punto sería 270 segundos,
aquí tenemos
veamos...
50, 100, 150, 200, 250
aquí estaría 270,
más o menos a la mitad
y 20 metros,
que estaría más o menos por aquí
estaría fuera de la región
que hemos puesto para la gráfica
pero siempre podemos ampliar esta región
si extendemos un poco el eje vertical...
vamos a extender el eje vertical
para poder incluir ese punto
aquí tenemos
14, 16, 18, 20...
por lo que ya pudimos graficar
todos los datos
así es que sí,
sí me gusta esta opción B
veamos ahora la opción C...
y la voy a hacer en azul...
esta es la gráfica C
tenemos la misma escala horizontal
que la gráfica B, 50
150, 200, 250, 300...
y el eje vertical tiene escala
de 10 en 10
10, 20, 30...
vamos a graficar los puntos...
vamos a graficar los puntos
en esta gráfica C
para empezar tenemos el punto
75, 5
entonces 75 para los segundos,
5 para los metros, lo tenemos ahí,
luego serían 120 segundos,
8 metros,
120 segundos ahí está 120,
mientras que 8 metros, está ahí,
y finalmente 270 segundos,
20 metros
270 lo tenemos aquí,
20 metros está aquí
y ahí tendríamos entonces
la gráfica de nuestros puntos
está bien...
todos los puntos caben pero,
por así decirlo,
se comprimen los valores de distancia
es difícil distinguir entre 5 y 8 metros,
pero bueno,
no está mal esta opción C.
Analicemos ahora la gráfica D...
analicemos la gráfica D...
se me están acabando los colores...
lo voy a hacer
en este café
no, no se ve muy bien...
lo voy a hacer en blanco... lo voy a hacer en blanco...
entonces la escala es
de 200 para el eje "s"...
400,
con eso es suficiente para nuestros datos
y para el eje "m"
2, 4, 6...
6,
8,
10,
12, 14,
tenemos el punto 75, 5
a ver aquí tenemos 200,
la mitad es 100,
así es que 75 estaría más o menos
por aquí
y 5 para la distancia,
estaría aquí
luego el punto 120, 8
que estaría más o menos por aquí y
y finalmente el punto
270, 20
270 y 20
que quedaría más o menos por aquí
así es que esta es la gráfica D
y al igual que en la opción C
pudimos graficar todos los datos
pero los datos se ven por así decirlo,
comprimidos
no se pueden distinguir entre sí
en la gráfica C
se comprimen el eje vertical
mientras que la gráfica D,
se comprimen en el eje horizontal
concluyendo
definitivamente descartamos la opción A
b es muy buena opción pues se puede distinguir
claramente las diferencias en las distancias
en la gráfica C,
las medidas se comprimen para el eje vertical
mientras que en la gráfica D, las medidas se comprimen
mucho para el eje horizontal
no uso completamente el espacio,
por así decirlo,
así es que yo diría que la gráfica B
tiene la mejor escala
para los datos que tenemos aquí...
déjame corregir,
este no es el color que use para B,
la gráfica B
es la que presenta la mejor escala
para los datos.